Hồi đồng nhân dân thành phố Hà Nội đã thông qua nghị quyết về vùng phát thải thấp, quy định gấm sẽ máy trảy sàng
lưu thông theo空 dờ mọi trong phạm viết sách định thuộc vàng đe một tự ngày 1 mộn tấm bẩy năm 2019.
Thông nghị quyết, Xe mô tô và xe gắn máy sự dụng sang sẽ bị hạn chế hoặc gấm lưu thông
tuy tường khu vực thời điểm, các vương tiện thành nghề trên nền tạm ứng dụng không được phép hoạt động trong vùng phát thải thấp.
Ôi tô không đặt tư chuyển khí thải mức bốn sẽ bị hạn chế và tiền tối gấm lưu thông theo lộ chiến.
Thành phố đặt mục tiêu chuyển đổi sang cho phương tiện kinh dành vận thải dụng như liệu hã thải.
Sẽ máy phải hoàn tất chuyển đổi trước năm 2019, tư mũ một tháng bẩy năm 2019,
thắc xí chỉ được đồng tư mới bằng steadyện hoặc phương tiện sự dụng năm 2019.
Tư mũ một tháng một năm 2019, Ui Bán nhân dân thành phố sẽ quyết định thời điểm và phạm vi hạn chế,
các rại phương tiện đường bộ,推 theo điều kiện từ tế.
Tư mũ một tháng bẩy hành dình khu劇 tháng 20 xấu, hà nội thị điểm bốn phát thải thấp tại một số phương trong vánh đe một,
như 2 bài trương, cửa năm, khoan kiếm, ô trợ dờ, phân miếu, quốc tử giám, bà đình, giảng vó,
ngọc, hà, và tư hồ. Đến năm hành dình khu劇 tháng 20, phạm vi mở giộng xa toàn vánh đe một,
và một phân vánh đe hai, vùng các phử lắng, đống đà, viêm liên, vạc mai và viện tuyệt.
Tư năm hành dình khu劇 tháng 20, trên 2 tải vánh đe ba, với tầm cộng 3 mi sấu phương 3 của 3 vánh đei.
Vực sây dựng vùng phát thải thấp, được sắc định là dải pháp trọng tâm, nhằm dạm ô nhiễm khu khí và khai thiện trất lượng dống của người dân.